before we get started I have the only
reason I get to do these interviews is
because of the house of Aurora there are
great sponsor partner I want to give
them a huge shout out Thank You House of
Aurora first of all good morning when
did you guys read TIFF and I'm curious
for each of you this is my favorite Film
Festival I love the energy here what
does it mean for each of you to be a
part of this festival and when did you
find out that you were gonna be a part
of the festival oh let's see
I think was about just over a month ago
I have never been to Toronto before to
the festival I've shot here a lot over
the years but I think we should found
out about you know six weeks ago or
something but I had no idea at that time
that we were a special presentation and
I had no idea that we were gonna be in
that unbelievable theatre the winter go
well I was born in Canada and spent a
lot of my early childhood here and have
shot in Toronto and been in Toronto and
done the jury for tip and previous years
so it's really meaningful and really
special and really you know it's it's
it's it this is a big deal that we get
to from your teeny tiny little movie and
such a beautiful home festival and it's
a beautiful festival to come to I've
only ever been to Toronto for cessful
and I love the city but there's not a
shot here
I know I know I'd love to actually I
love it um but it's always seems to be a
great array of movies and the audiences
here are so passionate they always feel
like it's them very kind of filmmaking
driven festival and you know the
question is are always so interesting
because it's usually like film students
and it does feel like like such a kind
of champion and that's what playing
vegetables is supposed to be about yeah
you know completely I hate asking
generic questions but I have to do one
which is everyone watching this
you will not have seen the movie yet
it's gonna you know what I mean so could
you talk a little bit about what the
film is about let's just start with that
okay so the film is really I would say
probably thematically it's about change
ultimately but it's a love story between
an unexpected love story about between
two women at the 1950s in Scotland and
they're both marginalised outside women
who find solace support and intimacy
with each other for each of you what was
it about this project that said I want
to be a part of it look you know the
first time you read the script was it
just talked a little bit about that and
when I read the script I just thought it
was a beautiful story of about
relationships that really and from two
lonely Outsiders that come together and
help each other and and they leave the
relationship it was far more self-worth
and confidence and understanding and I'm
able to to take that into their future
lives and I put and it has such a
positive ending and I think that is
quite rare and stories particularly sat
in this time about this kind of
relationship and I am and so it was
really beautiful to have this kind of
story with such a positive message in
the end it just felt incredibly truthful
to me and very real and ugly in the
right ways and beautiful in the right
ways and about ultimately sort of how
people connect and that sometimes to be
happily ever after ending where everyone
skips off into the sunset or somebody
dies as we were asked for Peters
community today is it nice to do a
romance film where nobody dies it was
like actually yes yes yes I just
realized that oh my
that's very true yeah yeah no one has to
be punished and and our film does not
ultimately end with how to you know
females living a happily ever after life
together but it ends with them both
being set free in ways that are
emotionally completely sort of
impossible to imagine at the beginning
of the film and gives them courage and
gives them new lives and which is
ultimately I mean isn't that kind of
what loves about mmm-hmm
blew it when I speak to a lot of actors
and everyone that I've spoken to has
obviously a different process on set
some people love silence
some people love music it's all about
you know what makes them comfortable to
get ready how do you two like to work on
set and was it like a like a match
I like 7,000 live bees chasing you
around the swamps and locks of Scotland
in the rain it makes me really happy and
right I also really enjoy waiting for
bees so sigh that they want to come out
of their hives because they don't like
that leather I like pop tea right Susie
that's cold
right but I mean being serious do you
like like the silence before you go on
you have like a thing where you like
you're looking to music or I have a
couple of different sort of philosophies
on that one was from a very dear friend
who directed the first play I was ever
and who said that you can't take the
music onstage with you so don't put it
in your ears right when you're trying to
prepare and that like it's actually not
necessarily helpful to sit with
something that you cannot then take out
onstage with you
however the noise of being on a concert
is extraordinary and sometimes you do
need to cocoon yourself so I kind of go
50-50 on that one and for you and
I guess it depends on the project in the
character and how its how the crew as a
whole is developing and the process of
the director so I I feel like it shifts
all the time but I always know I need to
find a grounding in a reality of the
scene that I'm in it's like I need to
know where everything is like kind of a
you know it's creepy hands of people or
props it's like where are my where and
whereas the physicality of what I meant
and that they can move so from outwards
in general how I'm curious the way you
like to have the energy on set as a
director and has your process changed
throughout your career well in this
particular case it was just such a fast
and furious shoot that there really
wasn't a lot of time to process yeah
it's a process we would just do you know
we were just like just tunneling through
ideally I mean in my ideal world I love
to have rehearsal time and we were very
fortunate in having that time because we
didn't really have a lot of time to do
much prep for specific scenes once we
were on set so it was a lot of talking
and debating actually about what the
intention was ultimately and so we so
the process for me was in the prep I
would say more so than having to have
anything specific and also we were you
know we hadn't I think that in this
particular case we had to be very
resourceful because we only had very
limited locations so we had to you know
we were such fast turnaround on every
scene from day to day and we were
shooting so quickly so I was so thankful
to have the prep time with ya know but
that's actually one of the really
beautiful things about independent
filmmaking is that you end up having to
be more creatively resourceful because
you don't have all the toys and you
don't have all the money and there's no
oh we'll come back and get it tomorrow
or this location doesn't work we're
gonna find him you know you have what
what you have and that's it and you
better get it and you better get it fast
and it makes people
very quick on their feet and sometimes I
think really inspirational things
transpire in those sorts of quite tense
situations that I think are actually
kind of amazing which you just don't
have on a huge film where you have where
you can be a bit a little bit lazy
German about your time and how you
manage it yeah I'm sure that on indie
filmmaking maybe it's more happy
accidents because you're just barreling
through you know yeah but also people
just you know you end up it's still
making me as a team sport you end up
going with whoever has the best idea and
that's not necessarily the person whose
job it was to have that idea it's
whoever actually was like oh hey we
could do this like this and then
suddenly the whole day is saved by you
know one person who maybe doesn't have
that job title but had a good idea
because they had buys and they were
paying attention and they cared sure
what did you learn from any early
screenings that impacted the finished
film we only did one early screening
which we did have a questionnaire that
we put out to everybody so the feedback
was very interesting actually there was
there was well I don't know you know
without giving too much away or no
spoilers yeah you know there's there's
an element of other worldliness about
this story and some people that just
doesn't sit comfortably with and others
absolutely love it so there was a bit of
a mixed reaction to that I think there
was actually quite a lot of surprised at
how dark there are parts of the film
became because ostensibly with the love
story it didn't seem as though it was
going to go to those places but it does
and there is definite even though it's
not fortunately out to women that suffer
that but so I think that was it was it
was very interesting actually getting
getting that feedback there was nothing
specific that would we you know that we
could do to change it because that
is it made me the story but it was
fascinating having one input before I
run out of time with you guys everyone
who's been coming in has been playing
something called get to know your tip
attendee I swear these are harmless
questions although she looked very
nervous okay
so for the two for the actors what TV
show would you love to guest spot on and
what TV show would you love to guest
direct I would love to guess direct
succession everyone is talking about
that show right now it is fantastic
Shakespearean contemporary fantastic
character development tremendous
performances the acting is phenomenal
and it just it just hits every beat I
would love to do that I want to be on
the west wing back when Aaron Sorkin was
still writing it yes I literally binge
watch season after season of that like
it's a lullaby right like every there's
a question coming up that always made
further masterclass yeah no I but I want
to be literally be Allison Janney I mean
if I could go back in time or if they
ever do another season Idol I just loved
the wire that would be like depending on
like our goals but at the moment I keep
finding myself watching both the crown
and transparent which are both like
totally different and the idea of like
guess what things that are completely
separate from each other look is quite
you know can i yes tonight can I go one
more time or less yeah take to chummy oh
yeah yeah because I have a huge love of
music and actually performance and so
that was a show that I just would have
just that would have been my dream job
it's interesting about Treme if you
haven't seen it I've been
New Orleans many times after watching
Treme going back completely different
appreciation for New Orleans oh well I
haven't yet I'm yet to go to New Orleans
I'm gonna be oh you're gonna have a
blast one of our True Blood directors
was one of the creators on that so it's
you guys have a favorite sci-fi or
fantasy film I do is 2001 this Cooper
got yeah yeah I feel like I'm gonna be
disloyal to like 17 different frames
part of in some way by yeah so I decline
to answer on the audience's that my
answer may offend people that I
understand I understand it's all good
[Laughter]
but it comes to sci-fi but you know
anything that would that would kind of
it dress me up in something ridiculous
[Laughter]
under the skin it's just one of my most
favorite films ever
yeah and books I just think it's just
it's such an unusual science fiction
thing yeah but it is science what's the
background photo on your phone
my kids my daughter whatever the fan
came is what movie have you watched more
than 20 times the deposit music
gold rush also true romance these are
all right
do you own any movie or TV show props
definitely I mean I can't think what I
think I still have a tea set from the
piano Wow Wow yeah it's currently like
basically cetera Simon others
I have a genetic electric dreams /it
yeah we did the same yeah we did the
sailors 24 and poaching yeah I knew I
was gonna buck yeah um but I had I was
just cool to food maker and I have a
hood superjealous on that note I'm going
to say thank you so much for coming in I
so appreciate it congratulations on
being part of TIFF and if you look to
the right you will see many other people
gone it's a wooden penis oh it's
actually from a commercial cadaver
supposedly and it was for a sports drink
and the wooden penis had to actually
have an erection underneath the cloth
that covers you and so it was really
complicated make it doing a realistic
penis that's you
going through the motions I'm gonna tell
you something really funny
before we wrap apparently during Game of
Thrones when Tyrion there was a set with
a brothel and they had a lot of wooden
penises and they sent out an email to
all the Game of Thrones people saying
please stop stealing the wooden penis
well we have an orgy on True Blood
Season three I think and we had poor
unfortunate young pas that had to go
around on police that people weren't
actually having sex
oh gosh that's amazing it's like what's
your experience
Game of Thrones I would guess boy no I
mean I'd do anything in them
Thanksgiving or the Game of Thrones
that's kind of good but listen I know
you have other stuff to know yeah I
really sincerely thank you so much
Congrats I'm super happy I could help
promote the movie thank you so much
thank you
[Music]